hello and welcome to the shaky science
show so in this video we'll look at how
do
NAD+ levels change during the day so to
help address this question I've split
the video up into full sections that
will go either the circadian clock
basics then we'll look at some of the
enzymes involved in nad synthesis and
its regulation throughout the day and
then finally we'll talk about how nad
Plus levels themselves actually
fluctuate during a day but before we go
any further what actually is nad well
one quick that I really like from David
Sinclair is that you could argue that
nad plus is the most important molecule
in the body perhaps with the exception
of ATP because you'll be dead in 30
seconds without it so nad which stands
for nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide is
a really important cofactor found in the
body and is actually one of the most
abundant molecules in our bodies and so
energy has three main functions one of
which is to act as a redox cofactor and
so energy is really important in
metabolic processes and also is a
substrate for nad plus dependent enzymes
so in a previous video where I talked
more about nmn one of the upstream
components of nad plus we looked at nad
plus metabolism and the role of these
different enzymes and what we came to is
we we discussed how nad Plus levels
actually changed during the day and this
is the link between nad plus and the
circadian clock but only is the nad plus
levels and output the clock it also has
a role in driving the clock as well and
last time I said that it was too
complicated to go into full details and
say I'm going to go into more detail in
this video even though nobody actually
said they wanted the video I decided to
make it anyway so let's talk about the
circadian clock so the circadian clock
is a really important biological process
that enables us to adapt different
processes in the body to the correct
time of day and so these include 24-hour
cycles and behavioral physiology
metabolism i'm selectivity discovery of
the components involved in the circadian
clock was the same much importance that
I was awarded the neighbor
in Physiology or medicine in 2017 so how
does the circadian clock regulate a
24-hour rhythm so I went into more
detail about this in a previous video
but to understand this video I'll go
over just the key concepts for you to
understand so in the mammalian [ __ ]
there are four key protein components
they're kind of like the essential parts
to the circadian rhythm and so this
includes clock beam r1 cryptochrome and
periods and say in the clock clock and
[ __ ] kind of they interact and they form
diamonds together and also cryptochrome
and periods
they also pair together and so these
proteins basically coordinate this
24-hour rhythm in a variety of different
cell processes and this is referred to
as the transcription translation
feedback loop so how does this work then
so clock and B male 1 I believe
transcription factors so what this means
is they can bind DNA and regulate the
expression of different genes say clock
and be mobile as I already said they
pair together and they give into the
nucleus of a cell and they bind DNA and
they up regulate the expression of a
variety of different genes but two
really important genes that they up
regulates is cryptochrome in periods and
say critical in periods as I said they
pair together and what they do is they
form a complex with clock and be my one
and actually repress the activity of
cork and be my one so by repressing
clock and be my one they then prevent
that in expression and so this negative
feedback loop regulates that 24 hour
cycles in one of these different
metabolic and physiological processes
that go on in the cell and so in
addition to cryptochrome in periods
another gene that they are prepping it
is nicotinamide phosphate ribosome
transferees or na MPT or lamps I have
let you know idea highest places it
let's go phenoms because it's easy to
say so what is mountains well as I
mentioned in a previous video talking
about nmn lamped is a protein that
converts nicotinamide into enema
and then Elliman can then be converted
into NAD+ so as a consequence of being
regulated by law can be mob on the
expression levels of noms also
fluctuates during a 24-hour cycle and so
this has consequences for understanding
the levels of NAD+ throughout the day as
well so as I said lumps adds a phosphate
ribosome oil teats you nicotinamide and
that converts nicotinamide into anime
and synapses actually be rate-limiting
enzyme in the salvage pathway of
regenerating NAD+ so actually the levels
of nouns is really important for
dictating the amounts of NAD+ that's
present in the body so how did the
protein levels of Nam's change
throughout the day
well there's been a very good study
published in science that'll link in the
description that looked at how the left
the levels of lamps fluctuates in Mouse
liver throughout the day so what the
examples they measured the levels at
different time points what I'm drawing
along the bottom here shows in white
that's the daytime and colored in black
is nighttime say that's actually the
site Gaber time so cero actually
represents dawn whereas at 12:00 that
regulates and dictates dusk and say in
mice because they're nocturnal they have
their highest levels of lamps during the
night time which is when they're active
and correlates with when the clock and
Beamer wine are also active it's that
kind of make sense so how do you NAD+
levels fluctuates in this mouth level
well they pretty much mirror what
happens but then amped levels which
basically shows that this fluctuation
and lamps will also alter the synthesis
of NAD+ so we can see that NAD+ levels
fluctuate so how does that affect the
activity levels of these NAD+ dependent
enzymes so the one that I'll focus on
because it's also linked into the
circadian clock our site winds also
Tuan's i've had this argument before I
don't know which is the right way to say
it and south winds are NAD+ dependent
enzymes that remove
acids our groups from proteins
and the consequence of removing acetyl
groups and proteins can affect the
function or the activity level of that
protein and so when the reaction is
complete you have your protein - the
acetal group and you have nicotine
amides instead of NAD+ so as I said
sirtuins
are energy plus dependent the s lasers
and they respond to the nutrient levels
in the cell because they require NAD+
for their activity so it shouldn't be
surprising then that there's also a
circadian fluctuation in sirtuin
activity and so in mice there's also a
diurnal oscillation of the activity
levels and you have a peak activity at
the site givataim 15 which correlates
with the highest peak in the lamps
levels and the NAD+ levels so if we get
back to our map we see that increased
lamps increases NAD+ which increases
certain activity and so it's a little
bit more complicated than that because
in humans we actually have seven
different twin enzymes so certain one to
seven and each of these different sized
ones they bind NAD+ but they all bind
energy plus the different affinities and
you can get this affinity by looking at
the km value for the different site ones
so km is the Michaelis constant and it
effectively is a value that is the
substrate concentration so in this case
would be the nad plus concentration
where you have the half maximum activity
of the enzyme so you can think of it as
the lower the the constant the lower the
substrate concentration the better right
because you're going to have a greater
activity at a lower level of energy plus
so therefore the search ones that have a
higher constant so you set one and set
free they require higher levels of nad
plus to have a greater activity level so
the daily fluctuations and nad plus are
going to affect the activity of these
two sites once more and this is
interesting because search one is the
sirtuin in humans that is found in the
nucleus
and say when you have increased naps and
you have an increase in 80-plus we know
that we're going to increase the set to
our levels and sat.1 actually represses
the clock because it removes the acetyl
group from Bheema bond which prevents
the activity of bhima on see it's got
the negative feedback loop which shows
how energy plus can also drive and
interrupt the clock as well as being an
output of the clock and it's even more
complicated than that because energy
plus is also required by another nad
plus dependent enzyme pop one and pop
one adds poly adp-ribose it's a clock
and the addition of this moiety to clock
actually weakens the binding of clock to
DNA and say what will weakens binding to
DNA the the expression of the genes is
also weakened and say again this has an
extra feedback loop and represses the
clock very complicated so in case I lost
some of you let's just summarize and
reiterate what I've just been saying so
based on the research we can see that
there's circadian fluctuations in nad
plus and this is as an output of the
clock through the circadian regulation
of nouns but we also see that 3d
activity of certains and pop one it can
also modulate and regulate the clock as
well so that's as an input so how do you
energy plus levels fluctuate during the
day the question of this video so live
our NAD+ levels show a bimodal circadian
oscillation pattern so I'm going to
redraw routes waited earlier because
what I did earlier was a bit messy but
this is effectively comes from the
research paper that I have linked in the
description because they look like the
energy plus levels throughout the day
and so what we see is we see this
bimodal oscillation pattern but we will
have that peak NAD+ levels at the site
gave a time of 15 and so we see this
bimodal oscillation because it's always
that highest peak occurs once every 24
hours even though we see two individual
peaks in oscillation so if the circadian
clock has a 24 hour of reckoning
by to BCT Peaks well that's because it's
still more complicated and we know that
energy plus levels are going to be
affected by exercise eating and fasting
periods age and now with the use of nad
precursors such as MMN and and our
supplements as well and so I hope this
video has given a good introduction to
how nad Plus levels watch rate
throughout the day and I've always been
listening